happy 35th anniversary to the legend of
zelda
is something nintendo never said the
35th anniversary for the widely beloved
legend of zelda franchise has come and
gone
and too many people's disappointment the
series production company known as
nintendo who you may or may not have
heard of stayed
silent the entire day leaving
celebrations or recognitions of the
series's anniversary up to the fans or
even other video game producers
nintendo clearly just doesn't care
anymore right i mean in the words of mr
penguin zero
and i don't even need to i think it's
pretty clear nintendo doesn't
care for the people that buy their games
in fact they go a step further and say
that they genuinely
hate them i don't think that's a stretch
to say i really don't guess this is the
end guys
gg we had a good run but it's over now
breath of the wild 2 is
cancelled future zelda games are
canceled heck i'm pretty sure metroid
prime 4 is canceled at this point what's
that
shut up now guys i hope it was obvious
that i was being sarcastic just now but
if it wasn't
i was being sarcastic nintendo does care
and will be moving not only onwards but
upwards from this point if you
concentrate on what nintendo currently
has going
on and what they've promised and what
their pattern has been in the past and
crunch a few numbers
the proof is in the pudding not only are
there some very
simple possible reasons for their
silence a couple days ago but there are
also
big plans in place for the legend of
zelda so let me tell you why i think
nintendo quote unquote forgot about
zelda's anniversary
reason number one mario more
specifically
mario's 35th anniversary which included
the release of one
super mario 3d all-stars you know that
video game that's actually a collection
of three video games that was released
last year you see the game is limited
edition and when is it going to be
pulled from all stores including online
march 31st 2021 over
a month from now that's right until
march 31st hits in super mario 3d
all-stars is officially pulled from all
stores
we're still technically in the
celebration time frame for mario's 35th
anniversary
from a business standpoint because we do
have to remember that nintendo is a
business
and if they don't achieve financial
success we won't be able to
experience nintendo games anymore it
doesn't make much sense to divert
attention away from your cash cow
especially when that cash cow is limited
edition corporations do this
all the time take mcdonald's for
instance how many times have you heard
the mcrib
is back does this mean they aren't also
selling the other items on their menu
no they still are but what's the first
thing you'll see when you drive up to
any mcdonald's restaurant
the mcrib it's all over their windows
because it's their limited edition
seller and it's the same way with
nintendo and mario
they have the super mcrib 3d all-stars
and super mcrib 3d world plus spicy
nuggets as fury plastered on their
website to promote its limited edition
sales
the legend of mcdouble might have hit
its 35th anniversary recently but that
doesn't change what they're currently
promoting and this is especially true if
they know that they have some good
legend of mcdouble content coming later
in the year wouldn't you say
reason number two pokemon and it feels
so good
its 25th anniversary is also this week
now let me put something into
perspective real quick
here in our everyday non-nintendo
executive lives we have what's called
fans fans of zelda fans of mario fans of
pokemon fans of metroid what's that
different people love different
franchises more or less than they love
others depending on the person
however if you look at the franchises
from the perspective of the executives
from nintendo
this is absolutely the opposite of the
case you see they value these franchises
numerically as in by the number of
dollars and cents they each are valued
at
so here we have two game franchises
anniversaries coming up at around the
same time
as a company you want to give each of
them special attention and focus on them
one at a time
but when two pop up really close to each
other which one would an executive of a
company decide to focus on
first the more valuable franchise
obviously and guess what
pokemon isn't just a little bit more
valuable than zelda it's about
25 times more valuable you heard me
25. zelda as a franchise is worth about
4 billion dollars which is
huge but pokemon the giant is worth an
overwhelming 100 billion dollars and it
feels so good
i mean it's worth three times as much as
the mario franchise which is valued at
about 35 billion
so when you look at their situation here
they have two franchises birthdays
popping up at just about the same time
and they're still trying to wrap up the
last big franchise's anniversary
so why would they take any of the
spotlight away from by far what is their
most
highly grossing namesake of all time
especially
when that namesake is experiencing its
25th anniversary which let's face it is
a much more impactful number than 35
now to us the fans this can sound just
asinine
but to the executives it's necessary
reason
number three for their forgetfulness we
the fans you see at the end of the day
finances and franchise numbers aside
nintendo understands that they have a
very highly critiqued and highly
publicized existence i mean they just do
because of us we tend to overanalyze
every little thing they put out there
especially
zelda fans i mean here we are nearly two
years later still making theories on the
minute and a half breath of the wild 2
trailer am i right
any fan of nintendo games worth their
salt has to admit that we would read way
too far
into any celebration post about zelda i
mean they could have said something as
simple as hey thank you for 35 years and
we'd have thousands of people trying to
look for a secret message or thousands
of comments saying wow nintendo really
no new trailer or wow nintendo really
just a post or nintendo clearly doesn't
care about their fans anymore when in
reality they
know we're expecting that stuff and they
just don't have enough for a new trailer
and they don't want to disappoint people
or they simply want to focus on the
franchise greater at a later point in
the year
it sucks to admit but i would definitely
be in that group
disappointed that i didn't see exactly
what i wanted to see and the only real
way to not disappoint anyone with the
details
is to not provide any details at all
clearly this will still disappoint
people of course but
what it won't do is mislead anyone's
already volatile expectations
further i know it's a hard pill to
swallow but maybe this will help you
think about what the effects will be in
the long run before
going on your next anti-nintendo rant or
not that's fine you do what you want
rant about who you want that's fine
now the final reason and the most
legitimate reason
is probably because of their future
plans for zelda as i mentioned before
there are several reasons to believe
this if we remember what was covered in
the recent nintendo direct regarding
zelda
they opened up by saying we have breath
of the wild 2 news confirmed coming
later this year
now listen at this point anyone who's
anyone in the gaming world knows about
breath of the wild and knows about its
sequel
and for the first time since its
original trailer in june
2019 we have a confirmed expectation
about the game
think about that that's a pretty huge
reason to hold off any big announcements
or news
they'll probably want to do it all
together and it'll still be 2021 which
is still
zelda's 35th anniversary year by the way
and on top of that we actually do
have a zelda related date to look
forward to in 2021
skyward sword hd releases on july 16th
they've definitely been fans in the past
of summer game announcements so i don't
know about you but come july i'm gonna
have my ears open and before i end this
video remember the anniversary for
breath of the wild is also
next wednesday when it will turn four
years old this is a minor point and i'm
not saying get hyped for
a for sure announcement on that day but
i'm just putting the possibility out
there
anyway i hope this helped with
everyone's disappointments or confusions
and if you enjoyed this real life theory
video of mine leave a like below so we
can get this speech sent out to other
nintendo fans out there
and hope to help the hype for just a
little bit longer and be sure to
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more nintendo content to come
thank you very much for watching and as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is maskington abandoned signing out
[Music]
you